hello and welcome to this video am
turbulence something 12 insurances okay
symmetrical english i can get all or
Kansas positions from him it seemed
right at six g6 also play this one yes
after the main line of his opening I
don't know it all that well I have to
admit yeah I was just thinking he might
be able to play that okay and I takes
what what exactly is the deal here we
should a 60 on what I mean not taking
what's really out of the question what
exactly is the ideas Queen B 6 on
okay from 95 if I go before a bit Knight
b6 I had booked c6 maybe doesn't do all
that much look c6 I alex is six days
bishop to be seven okay
[Music]
it's a bit of a shame really hmm if I go
85 where does the night go exactly I
mean that pin is probably too strong
so i can i play something that like
night is for layin light discovery or
something to c7 lamia song that made is
that possible night a 497 for a double
attack essentially two bit strange but
[Music]
the only thing I saw we should be too
probably to screen a form yeah I love
those miracle defenses yeah that works
yeah night hangsen 1c7
what now you're not taking the c7 night
maybe because I mean this should be to
somehow in
what a sick game
let me see that's extremely sick so yeah
whatever this should be to order this
should be too would have been funny and
it wouldn't work but so would have been
funny so we own the night on 67 I cannot
really rescue the speed self going back
is the kind of thing but you know your
switch on the engine later and we'll
tell you the many ways how we could have
refuted it it's absolutely certain so
maybe I can play for the a pole or
something if it takes I'm going to
exchange down at the pawn down
ok
anyway here to still fight at least a
little bit nine morning would be sweet
to somehow some are try air but it's
just lost unfortunately bring the bishop
around there now fortunately not
and just to basics and yet it was
completely completely unnecessary loss
one of those I be five is just bogus re
really yeah no of course not how do I
should stop that and so let's see how
this can be refuted so I'm taking this a
4 and this is really just a pawn for
knowledge and of course so be formed 96
so not because queen bee three in 94 so
nine eight seven instead of yeah a 95
and this is just this kind of this kind
of miracle yeah that that does it I
didn't see it of course not a seven and
he just gives up threatened space
friends this and the whole stuff falls
apart and then it was clear that there
was something because this kind of
chances didn't work yeah you just give
up give up the B porn and whatever it
doesn't work but a FTF to see nine to
five I mean if not politely five this
was just what was just fall apart and
now I have to go to e3 instead of a 3
yeah because we should be to this work I
calculated that well I mean you have to
give him that credit start out with and
also the length starts start to play
well that that can work and this is just
equal am now I'm just understand very
bad shape you can cannot say that simply
it's basically just losing yeah and so
yeah nothing to do here but should be
three is a bit better
since that I could still fight with this
a bit instead of a six yams just to
preempt should be formed yes I actually
promoting this stuff is this a bit
tricky so the line here the line you
could could give me some drawing chances
even now well okay that's not the point
after we shoot this opening and not to
hang around in this in this bad ending
ok guys thanks for watching